you're not ashamed of it at all you go
with it which is you love free stuff
you've worked hard to become a celebrity
I went to school what talent you had and
then you work really hard and you know
what you said what talent I had I don't
know you in past tense past tense but
anyway you know you work you work really
hard you're talented guy you like being
a celebrity but you will use it to get
free stuff and you're very upfront about
it yeah and I learned that from you guys
I know that see did you learn it from us
okay so this was because we don't do a
lot of that I swear to god we don't Yeah
right so I got it but okay this is when
I was watching the show when it was on
in 1976 and the Bee Gees were just
breaking up on who was exciting yeah no
you did this thing where Andy talked
about it where you go we did a bit last
night and we just mentioned dohsa keys
once accidentally it was in I guess yeah
and and then the next day you had a
youth that here went we said dohsa keys
on the air and then dohsa keys sent us
like nine cases of Dos Equis yes and we
didn't realize that that was something
that happened we were kind of blown away
by it and that's when we started doing
lots of sketches with like Porsche in it
come here mr. Lamborghini
but anyway but you let so bad as soon as
I got when I was on third tier cable for
12 years I exploited that I hosted
fashion police and I exploited that too
so I would mention stuff I would get I'd
I my wife hates it cuz stuff piles up
and then I go it's mine and and I I just
love get I like it's a set I have shoes
that I get I just got a an electric bike
now where did you mention the electric
bike lithium cycles I haven't mentioned
them yet
[Applause]
really yeah have you heard of lithium
say I have not heard of them no oh
they're a great company in Tustin they
make a beautiful lithium cycle it looks
like a 19-7 it looks like it has a
banana seat it looks like a 1970s
bicycle which yes so would you like one
because of you said if we all say it
together I think they're gonna send 800
I think I'm good I'm good I don't want
to exploit the the good people at
lithium probably trying to make a living
and sell these bikes for real money and
then shysters like you come along I am
NOT a I feel like I'm giving them a
great commercial here for lithium cycles
lithium cycles within cycles and you
should call them at three four three no
I now and there's more yeah you know
Annie will back me up on this there'll
be times where it's just random in a
sketch where we just mention some random
brand name and it's usually something we
don't even really want and the next day
there's like 900 fish sandwiches from a
fast food place because we accidentally
showed their wrapper not even intending
to but it's nine hundred or something we
don't really even want right you know so
if you went on the air and said man we
got a lot of fish sandwiches and we
don't even want them and then mention
the company's name do you think they
would try to burn down the studio or
something I do not want a feud with Long
John Silver's
what are you shaking your head for they
don't buy ad time on this thing do they
Jesus Christ do one more as I would cool
with you you good with that I would have
no time usually calling he's trying to
get a reservation at a restaurant hello
how's it going Pizza Hut you got room
[Laughter]
look at he's a powerful man in
television he can just go he's he chews
gum during his job yeah you can just
chew gum and sit on the phone or not
that's not gum it's money
[Applause]
you